bonsoir je suis assez timide et je vous
avoue c'est une grande première pour moi
donc ne me tenez pas rigueur si je suis
très honorée en même temps avec c'est
avec beaucoup d'humilité que je vais
essayer d'aborder deux thématiques qui
sont très importantes pour moi
aujourd'hui par rapport à la thématique
principale qui est énoncé c'est-à-dire
humains 2.0 alors quand on m'a invité
pour venir prendre parole devant vous
était un peu un peu surpris en me disant
maman moi pourquoi mois inquiète de
molenbeek identifie finalement ben on
m'a répondu très gentiment pour mon
optimisme alors est ce que travailler
avec les jeunes c'est être optimiste
certainement parce que pour pouvoir
travailler avec il faut donner le
meilleur de soi même donc on attelle à
être optimiste mais on est obligé d'être
optimiste avec les jeunes puisque c'est
notre futur c'est demain céder 2.5 3.0
et puis ça c'est cet optimisme
obligatoire celle du choix puis un autre
thème comme que j'aimerais un petit peu
abordé avec vous qui sont qui liés à la
jeunesse qui est lié à humain 2.0 et
qu'il y ait à nous tout simplement
c'est la spiritualité très très
brièvement et elle est très très
importante quand je parle de
spiritualité aujourd'hui je ne parle pas
de spiritualité démarche conceptuelle ou
dogmatique
on parle réellement d'aller vers une
connaissance de soi verts ale aller vers
la sagesse ou le dépassement de
délimitation de la condition humaine
c'est de ça que je parle aujourd'hui
parce que si on fait évoluer tout ce qui
tourne autour de nous on est obligé
d'évoluer avec
le matériel peut pas évoluer tout seul
sinon on va finir pas pu rien faire et
on va finir par mourir tous ensemble et
les robots seront nos seigneurs bref
donc vous dire que la spiritualité est
importante dans le sens où le monde va
très vite les technologies les
innovations mais les générations aussi
et depuis 2000 on a une génération tout
fait une génération internet
moi j'appelle cette gen jeunesse la
jeunesse internet oui c'est une
génération internet 2.5 3.0 pourquoi
parce qu'elle est née avec un clavier
une tablette dans la main nous on a la
chance pourtant je suis pas si vieux que
ça moi je suis né dans une commune où
voit la petite maison quartier très
populaire et alors on avait bien oui le
téléphone fixe et la télévision quand on
avait un peu de chance le lecteur vhs
aujourd'hui il a deux ans et l'envoi des
photos par whatsapp il ya un décalage
vous me dit tu veux manger quoi il est
capable d'aller chercher sur internet
pour voir ce qu'il va manger pas
uniquement
c'est de notre faute ainsi si cette
jeunesse part dans dans l'extrême de
l'internet dans l'utilisation extrême de
l'internet parce que dès le départ nous
n'avons pas mis de deux verrous
quand je dis un virus n'est pas
interdire l'utilisation d'internet celle
utilisée à bon escient su l'utiliser
pour des recherches pour pour pour
apprendre à apprendre mais certainement
pas pour vivre ce que nous avons vécu
ici
ces jeunes vivent par exemple cette
jeunesse sont avery voilà on a vu que il
ya eu 6 qui a eu en novembre en mars on
a découvert que la méthode de
recrutement dans dans les activités dix
terroristes se passe par internet
et je précise je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce qu'il ya d'autres types d'attentât
et d'autres types de terrorisme sur
internet dont on ne parle pas on recrute
ses gamins et on les envoie au front
bref voilà l'internet a pris à une
réelle emprise sur le mental de nos
jeunes mais ya pas que le recrutement au
niveau voilà de la religion ou de
séquelles l'idéologie il ya le recrue il
ya le ne parlait pas pardon le
terrorisme intellectuel il ya le
terrorisme intellectuel
il ya ce qu'on appelle j'ai comme on dit
50e prendre petit à petit on fait des
choses un peu aller comment dire salles
intimes devant tout le monde d un
attentat à la pudeur d'antan la pudeur
et attentats le porno c'est du
terrorisme
le porno c'est une je sais pas faites
comme vous voulez mais c'est une bombe
qui peut qui perd toutes les 30 minutes
aux etats unis puisque c'est un film
pornographique qui sortent toutes les 30
minutes aux états unis et en 2016 on a
battu tous les records de visionnage de
niveau international sur une année de
pour nous ces trous moi quand je suis
avec les jeunes aujourd'hui et que on
est amoureux nous hein
on a peut-être vraiment connu ce que
c'était l'amour de deux genoux ou
d'adolescents
quand j'étais en primaire j'avais offert
une gomme parfumé ma première petite
copine quand j'étais dans secondaire
c'est ma copine qui venu ce n'est à la
maison mais on vivait ce rapport il y
avait quelque chose
notre coeur battait va dire oui à dire
non aujourd'hui c'est autrement la
relation virtuelle
déjà aujourd'hui quand je dis alors tu
comment ça se passe là tu d amour je
l'attrapé
ah bon ah ouais et vous montre la vidéo
mais là c'est plus rigolo moi je me plie
parce qu'à partir du moment où j'ai un
gamin de 13 ans 14 ans qui vient chez
moi qui me dit fier parce que l'image
qu'il a des adultes aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'il a comme image lui en tout cas
c'est que pour être un bonhomme faut
être un rock aux performances toujours
performance par les gars vous brûlez
donc ils te montre cette vidéo est fier
as-tu dit mais tu es fou quoi aux études
et à rien vu et il me montre l'autre
vidéo où c'est lui qui est monté en haut
et c'est son pote qui se fait reprendre
treize ans je vous dis je rigole plus la
jeunesse c'est quoi la jeunesse c'est en
parler un peu chiffres c'est aujourd'hui
les 10 24 ans 2 milliards de notre
population mondiale
on parle d'un quart de la population
10 24 ans j'ai pas parlé des héros dix
ans dans les 10 24 ans 9 10 24 ans sur
dix neuf dans des pays défavorisés ou en
tout cas se développer je vous parle de
cette jeunesse parce que c'est eux
demain ce que vous aurez dans votre
assiette
c'est eux moi je vous dis tout de suite
dans vingt ans dans 30 ans certains
aimeront qu'ils ont de la chance en
pension bon d'autres y voient là et très
passeront mais pour ceux qui seront en
pension quoi ils vont rester assis sur
un fauteuil non ils vont devoir faire
des choses ce fameux intergénérationnel
qu'on ne développe plus grâce à internet
ou à cause d'internet puisque comme vous
voulez vous comprenez la nécessité de de
souligner d'appuyer le susurre sur la
jeunesse donner la chance aux jeunes
donner les moyens aux jeunes et c'est
votre avenir à vous qui sera je veux
dire agréable stable qui va vous
permettre de vous découvrir vous même
donc la jeunesse aujourd'hui face à
toutes ces technologies d'un légiste
dépassé comme nous face à tout ce qu'on
vient de vivre
est ce qu'on vit d'ailleurs andré
malraux avait dit le 21e siècle sera
spirituel ou ne sera pas ça veut dire
si j'ai bien compris parce que je pense
que je les mange et cette phrase ça veut
dire bah si on met pas un peu de
spiritualité dans nos vies et peu
importe la confession ou pas parce que
la spiritualité c'est une quête c'est ce
qui va vous permettre de devenir
meilleur de pouvoir utiliser la tête et
le coeur en bonne intelligence d'oser
entamé les dialogues de choeur à coeur
ce qu'on ne fait plus aujourd'hui on
fait des dialogues d'écran à écrans le
28 sec sera spirituel ou ne sera pas
donc je disais le disait malraux parti
comme on est parti on va pas survivre à
notre siècle
parti comme nous sommes partis nous
n'allons pas survivre à notre siècle
il est impératif aujourd'hui de
travailler sur nos consciences sur nos
comportements parce que n'oubliez pas
vous est le reflet de quelque chose pour
ces jeunes n'oubliez pas que un jeune
qui se référa vous que vous le vouliez
ou pas et là tout à l'heure un monsieur
de nous disait j'aime bien être avec mes
enfants parce qu'il m'apprenne et les et
il ma classe au 6 mai mais bien sûr bien
sûr c'est la jeunesse qui nous montre ce
que nous on ne voit pas donc elle vous
apprend elle est connectée à sa façon
une génération pour pouvoir survivre
elle a besoin d'une autre génération
mais survivra comment c'est vous qui
allez déterminer votre futur de par
votre comportement vis-à-vis de ces
jeunes et pour avoir le bon comportement
il faut oser se poser les bonnes
questions
donc si pour conclure tout doucement si
je dois poser deux questions se la
première serait par rapport à la
jeunesse en disant qu'est-ce qu'on
laisse que ce qu'on donne comme bagage à
ces gamins que ce qu'on apporte et la
deuxième question peut-être serait
est-ce que la spiritualité serait une
thérapie pour les mots de l'homme
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand on dit mot on
parle de pas à pas que c'est complexe
les mots de l'homme aujourd'hui puisque
la complexité d'infériorité de
supériorité la jalousie l'égoïsme mais
pas que vouloir on dit toujours vouloir
à son prochain ce qu'on veut pour soi
mais quelque part c'est une vérité parce
qu'on ne peut pas avoir un équilibre de
vie si l'autre il a plus et l'autre il a
moins ce qui se passe dans nos quartiers
et d éducation à double vitesse des
soins de santé que certains peuvent se
permettre et d'autres pas comment
peut-on avancer aujourd'hui dans tous
les domaines elle ne pas avancer
humainement parlant
conclure moi je sais ce que j'avais
vraiment envie de vous dire vous dire
que si vous prenez pas le taureau par
les cornes
c'est celle là qui me vient tout de
suite c'est les cordes que vous allez
vous ramassez ce je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et merci pour moi
[Musique]